>>> GUYS, GREAT NEWS THIS WEEK.
THE CDC ANNOUNCED THAT FULLY
VACCINATED PEOPLE NO LONGER HAVE
TO WEAR MASKS OR SOCIALLY
DISTANCE -- EXCEPT IF YOU GO TO
MOST PLACES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ANYWAY, HAVE FUN OUT THERE.
>> COLIN, THAT IS SO TRUE --
STARBUCKS.
WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" AS YOU SEE
CAPTURED A LOT OF THE CONFUSION
THAT A LOT OF US ARE FEELING
AROUND THE CDC'S NEW GUIDANCE
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE FULLY
VACCINATED, FULLY VACCINATED
AGAINST COVID, YOU CAN GO OUT
WITHOUT YOUR MASK OUTDOORS AND
INDOORS IN MOST PLACES.
SO AT LEAST 20 STATES HAVE
REVISED THEIR MASK MANDATES
SINCE THE ANNOUNCEMENT ON
THURSDAY.
LARGE RETAILERS LIKE WALMART AND
TRADER JOE'S SAY THEY WILL NO
LONGER REQUIRE MASKS FOR FULLY
VACCINATED CUSTOMERS.
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
CRITICS POINT OUT JUST OVER 37%
OF THE U.S. POPULATION IS FULLY
VACCINATED WHICH IS LESS THAN
HALF.
DR. ASHISH JAH, HE'S DEAN OF
BROWN UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, JOINS US TO SORT
IT OUT.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, DR. JAH.
>> GOOD MORNING, GAYLE.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> WE ARE SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S EVER
GOOD WHEN THERE'S CELEBRATION
AND CONFUSION.
SO HELP US UNDERSTAND THE CDC'S
THINKING HERE WHEN YOU HAVE MORE
NON-VACCINATED PEOPLE THAN
VACCINATED PEOPLE, TO SAY THAT
IT'S OKAY TO TAKE OFF YOUR MASK
OUTDOORS.
AND INDOORS IN SOME CASES.
>> YEAH.
A COUPLE OF -- RIGHT.
COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED.
SECOND, THEY ARE RIGHT THAT IF
YOU ARE FULLY VACCINATED, IT IS
SAFE TO TIAKE OFF YOUR MASK.
THE PROBLEM, AS YOU SAID, IS A
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ARE NOT
FULLY VACCINATED, AND RETAILERS
HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS VACCINATED
AND WHO IS NOT.
THIS IS WHY I THINK IT'S WISE TO
OLD OFF ON LIFTING MASK
MANDATES FOR A FEW MORE WEEKS.
I'VE SAID JUNE 15th IS A
DEADLINE WHERE I THINK A GOOD
CHUNK OF AMERICANS WILL BE ABLE
TO GET VACCINATED.
AND AFTER THAT, WE PROBABLY CAN
GO AHEAD AND LIFT IT -- NOT
PROBABLY, WE SHOULD LIFT THE
MASK MANDATES.
>> SO MANY OF US ARE CONFUSED.
I WENT TO THE BOTANICAL GARDENS,
GORGEOUS PLACE, WHICH AS YOU
KNOW IS OUTSIDE, AND IT WAS MASK
ON, MASK OFF.
I DID MY THING ABOUT ASKING
PEOPLE AGAIN HOW ARE YOU
FEELING.
AND WE'RE ALL LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW.
SO I'LL LEAVE IT ON.
I THOUGHT JOHN DICKERSON SUMMED
IT UP BEAUTIFULLY OVER THE
WEEKEND WHERE HE SAID, YOU KNOW,
THIS BARE-FACED DELIGHT IS NICE,
BUT IT'S KIND OF LIKE WHEN
YOU'VE BEEN WEARING BRACES FOR A
LONG TIME, YOU TAKE IT OFF, YOUR
MOUTH FEELS FUNNY.
DO YOU THINK WE JUST HAVE TO
ADJUST TO IT?
IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
>> DEFINITELY.
I MEAN, I THINK THERE'S
DEFINITELY AN ADJUSTMENT PERIOD.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR -- OUTDOOR
MASK MANDATES MAKE ZERO SENSE AT
THIS POINT.
NO OUTDOOR PLACE SHOULD BE DOING
MASK MANDATES.
>> WHETHER YOU'RE VACCINATED
OVER NOT?
WHETHER YOU'RE VACCINATED OR
NOT?
>> CORRECT.
>> REALLY?
>> I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY IT'S MUCH,
MUCH SAFER IF YOU'RE VACCINATED.
BUT I THINK GETTING RID OF
OUTDOOR MASK MANDATES MAKES
SENSE RIGHT NOW.
SO FAR INFECTIONS HAPPEN IN THE
OUTDOOR SPACE.
IT'S ABOUT INDOOR SETTINGS AND
ABOUT THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> SO DR. JHA, I'M CURIOUS WHAT
YOU PERSONALLY ARE DOING.
WHAT ARE YOUR MASK RULES FOR
YOURSELF RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH.
SO YOU KNOW, I AM OBVIOUSLY
FULLY VACCINATED.
I STILL WEAR A MASK WHEN I GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE.
WHY?
BECAUSE IN MASSACHUSETTS PEOPLE
ARE GETTING VACCINATED, BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THERE ARE STILL
PEOPLE NOT FULLY VACCINATED YET.
I WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE TIME.
SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING TO
DO FOR A FEW MORE WEEKS.
WHEN I HAVE FRIENDS OVER WHO ARE
FULLY VACCINATED, I DON'T WEAR A
MASK.
I'VE GOTTEN RID OF MASKS IN A
LOT OF PLACES.
I CERTAINLY DON'T WEAR ONE
OUTSIDE.
BUT INDOOR GROCERY STORES, THAT
KIND OF PLACE, I'M STILL DOING
IT FOR A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
>> DO YOU LET NON-VACCINATED
PEOPLE COME TO YOUR HOUSE?
>> HAVEN'T YET.
>> BECAUSE --
>> THEY CAN SIT IN MY BACK YARD.
>> THIS IS THE THING, FAMILIES
GETTING READY TO GO ON VACATION,
WHAT DO YOU DO?
SOME MEMBERS ARE VACCINATED,
SOME ARE NOT.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA?
>> YEAH -- YEAH, LET ME BE VERY
CLEAR.
FIRST OF ALL, KIDS UNDER 12 WHO
CAN'T GET VACCINATED I TREAT
DIFFERENTLY.
THEY HAVE LESS RISK.
I DON'T WORRY ABOUT THEM, AS
MUCH.
AMONG ADULTS, I -- YEAH.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA FOR UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE TO BE MIXING WITH OTHER
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE.
I WOULD HOLD OFF ON THAT.
AND I WOULDN'T -- I ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GO AHEAD AND GET THE
SHOT.
>> AT THIS POINT HOW IMPORTANT
IS IT TO KEEP A TESTING REGIMEN
GOING GIVEN WHERE WE ARE?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THE YANKEES
ACTUALLY TAUGHT US THAT IT
PROBABLY -- THERE IS A VALUE TO
IT.
WE SAW THAT OUTBREAK.
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE --
EVERYBODY WAS VACCINATED.
MOST OF THEM HAD VERY FEW
SYMPTOMS.
I THINK HAVING SOME SORT OF A
TESTING REGIMEN IS HELPFUL IN
TRACKING ARE THERE INFECTIONS,
HOW OFTEN DO THEY OCCUR.
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW.
>> THEY WERE VACCINATED AND
STILL TESTED POSITIVE.
THAT'S NOT VERY COMFORTING.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW, THESE
VACCINES ARE TERRIFIC, THEY
PROTECT YOU FROM REALLY SEVERE
ILLNESS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT 100%.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE SOME
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT DOES HAPPEN.
IT'S TINY COMPARED TO BEING
UNVACCINATED.
MUCH LESS RISKY.
BUT WE WILL SEE THIS EVERY ONCE
IN A